over the past few years you might have
heard about the push to deal with
chinese companies from the u.s stock
market if they don't comply with u.s
auditing rules
initially this might seem like more of a
political move rather than an objective
move but a lot of evidence would
actually suggest that this move is
indeed warranted one of these examples
is a chinese starbucks copycat called
luck and coffee
just a few years ago luck and coffee was
a booming startup within china that had
seemingly unlocked the key to chinese
coffee lovers but all of this would come
crumbling down when it was revealed that
luken was faking hundreds of millions of
dollars worth of sales it's
all about the fabrication
of data i suppose and
the amount of sales it's had
when the news broke looking coffee
plummeted over 97
which wiped out basically every dollar
invested into the company so here's how
luck and coffee went from trying to
dethrone starbucks to being delisted
from the american stock market
taking a look back the entire fiasco
circles back to a man named lou zheng
yao lu started off his career as a
government bureaucrat who served in the
hebei province located just outside of
beijing but it didn't take him long to
switch over to the private industry in
the early 1990s when he saw technology
companies blowing up leading up to a
dot-com bubble lu decided to jump in on
the action by selling various parts
within the telecommunications industry
once the dock on bubble burst lou jumped
over to the rapidly growing chinese auto
industry by selling insurance and in
2007 he would open his own car rental
company called core inc lou was able to
raise hundreds of millions from foreign
investors and use that money to offer
car rental prices that were unheard of
car inc was barely making money given
that they were renting out these cars
for basically zero profit but given that
they were undercutting all the
competition it didn't take long for car
to build up a massive customer base by
2013 car was the largest rental provider
in china and their biggest competitor
hertz would actually give in by
purchasing a 20 stake in the company and
emerging their operations with a car but
just two years later hertz dumped most
of their position and car so maybe they
knew something about loose business
practices way back then but at the time
this was simply written off as a
financial move as hertz was losing
hundreds of millions themselves in the
meantime lou was praised for being a
masterful businessman who had the modest
touch he had succeeded in the
telecommunications insurance and rental
industries and his timing was impeccable
he knew exactly when to get in and
exactly when to get out so when lou
started talking about his vision for a
starbucks like coffee shop investors
were sold
you see it starbucks had been trying to
break into the chinese market for nearly
two decades at that point and though
they were able to grow a pretty sizable
operation they struggled to match their
success in western countries
this wasn't necessarily starbucks fault
though the problem was that coffee
simply wasn't that popular in china as
of 2018 annual per capita coffee
consumption came in at 388 cups in the
u.s in china it was just 6 cups or 64
times less
starbucks was well aware of this and
they tried to address this disparity by
selling the social aspect of their shops
but lou would take the exact opposite
approach blue told the media that he and
his colleagues had to become coffee
lovers as they put in long days trying
to grow car ink he suggested that coffee
was the perfect boost that the chinese
needed to get through long work days and
he felt that the only reason coffee
hadn't caught on in china was because of
lack of affordability as opposed to a
lack of demand starbucks didn't really
reduce their prices when they moved over
to china with the grand latte selling
for 4.57 cents or 32 won
in 2017 the average chinese citizen was
only making about 36 000 yuan so buying
a grand latte was equivalent to an
american spending 31 dollars on a cup of
coffee lou suggested that he could fix
this issue by embracing a new coffee
shop model based on kiosks and
automation unlike starbucks locations
lock-in locations had very little
seating if any they completely
eliminated the social aspect and simply
focused on reducing cost as much as
possible lock-in also required that
customers place their orders on the luck
and app which eliminated the need for
cashiers and to minimize labor costs lou
was hoping to eventually switch over to
smart vending machines that would
completely eliminate the need for
employees altogether but he quickly ran
into a brick wall the truth was
shrinking the stores and reducing labor
costs wasn't even close to making up for
the revenue disparity in 2018 operating
expenses were nearly triple sales
meaning that luckin spent nearly three
dollars for every one dollar of revenue
to make things worse it didn't take long
for starbucks to retaliate
in 2018 starbucks formed a partnership
with alibaba alibaba already had an
established delivery network which
starbucks could leverage this allowed
starbucks to set up their own kiosk type
stores called starbucks now with minimal
space and employees this significantly
increased the pressure on luck and
coffee but lou was still confident that
he just had to sustain the losses for
long enough to achieve incredible
economies of skill and to become
profitable but to sustain losses he
needed the help of foreign investors
so lou hired an investment banker named
ray now shackle reynad was appointed as
cfo of luck and coffee and he was the
only non-chinese executive at the
company fortunately for luck and coffee
reynad was able to open some big doors
in terms of funding by the end of 2018
lockheed was able to raise a total of
400 million dollars with one of their
most notable investors being singapore's
sovereign wealth fund with this influx
of capital lu was able to retaliate
against starbucks partnership with
alibaba by forming a partnership with
alibaba's biggest rival tensioned
alibaba might have been able to
circumvent loken's kiosk model but
alibaba had no chance at circumventing
tension's order flow tencent is the
owner of wechat which is a super app
that is capable of doing everything from
social media to mobile payments wechat
is ubiquitous in china boasting a total
of 1.2 billion active monthly users luck
and could easily advertise coupons and
discounts and promote luck into
basically the entirety of china through
tension this was a massive deal and got
major investors excited in april of 2019
luckily raised 150 million dollars 125
million of which came from blackrock but
the best way to raise money was of
course through the irrational public
markets so laka started working with
american banks to take luck in public
bank of america was selected to be one
of the underwriters of the ipo but bank
of america eventually backed out after
lock-in executives demanded for a higher
valuation than what bank of america gave
them nonetheless locken was able to
complete their ipo in may of 2019 with
the help of morgan stanley and credit
suisse luckily debuted at 17 dollars per
share but it would quickly rocket to 25
per share by the end of their first
trading day which valued the company at
5.88 billion dollars by the start of
2020 loken was killing it they had
overtaken starbucks in terms of
locations at the time starbucks had 3
600 locations while luckin had 4 500 and
the luckin's quarterly sales growth was
through the roof
in late 2019 luckily reported a
quarterly sales growth of 6x it seemed
like lou had done it again and investors
piled in confident that they were
investing into the next starbucks by
january of 2020 [ __ ] coffee stock had
grown to 50 dollars per share buying the
company at 11.8 billion to many
investors even this was a great price to
jump in
after all starbucks is worth 137 billion
so even if lockheed was able to go to
half the size of starbucks that would be
a 5x investment and this likely would
have been the case if lukkan wasn't
lying as luck and grew a massive
investor base they also built a massive
group of skeptics
to many investors luckn's growth numbers
were simply way too good to be true i
mean what type of company grows their
revenue six fold in a single quarter one
of these skeptics was a man named carson
block who was the founder of muddy
waters research carson had correctly
exposed another fraudulent chinese
company called cynoforce corporation a
decade ago and he sensed that luckin was
in a similar boat but he knew that
exposing a company as large as luck and
would be a massive undertaking
financially it would cost an absurd
amount of money to monitor thousands of
stores and search for disparities so
carson didn't even try to expose luck in
but someone else did an anonymous fund
manager had been wandering looking
coffee for a while and had already
uncovered massive disparities
the fund manager had hired 1 000
investigators to monitor the foot
traffic at lock-in locations across
china these investigators also collected
25 000 receipts from customers to
estimate the average cost of each order
using this data the fund was able to
estimate the quarterly sales of luck in
throughout the third and fourth quarters
of 2019 and the disparity between the
estimated sales and reported sales
wasn't 5 or 10
no it was 69 in the third quarter and 88
in the fourth quarter it was pretty
clear that lokken was faking sales but
the fund manager didn't want to release
evidence himself as he feared the
backlash he would receive from investors
so he asked carson to release the report
and carson would follow through as soon
as the report debuted in february 2020
luck and coffee plunged luck and coffee
of course refused allegations and many
investors refused to believe it but it
didn't take long for the sec to get
involved and once the sec got involved
luckily really had no choice but to come
clean they could avoid it until the sec
exposed them which would probably take
quite some time given how slow the sec
is
but when the sec did finally expose them
there would be no coming back for
lock-in as the sec's findings would
completely discredit the entire
executive team
so luckin's executives decided to pin
the blame on a couple of executives and
hopefully save face on april 2nd 2020
lucken admitted that the numbers were
overstated they tried to claim that the
fraud was carried out by two executives
named jenny kien and gianlu but that the
rest of the company was clean investors
didn't buy that story and luck and
coffee stock would jump into the abyss
in may nasdaq announced that they would
be delisting looking coffee from the
stock market at the end of june and
unsurprisingly luck and coffee would
plummet to less than one dollars per
share
in july luck and coffee confirmed that
300 million worth of sales was
fabricated and lou would be ousted that
same month cnbc estimates that
throughout the duration of the fraud
luxem was able to raise a total of 864
million dollars which basically
evaporated after they were exposed and
most positions ended up looking like
this
as for lou he claims that he was never
trying to deceive investors and that he
was just trying to grow lochen as fast
as possible and i do think he's
partially telling the truth it's not
like he was trying to run a pump and
dump he was actually trying to grow a
long-term company but he succumbed to
external pressures and turned to faking
it until he made it and unfortunately
for lou he never made it it should be
noted though that luck and coffee never
stopped operations and many back holders
still think that locking can make a
comeback but only time will tell
do you guys think that luck can make a
comeback or do you think that locking
should be shut down for the deception
comment that down below also drop a like
if you agree that foreign company should
be held to the same ordering standards
as american companies
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one